you guys excited
jojo has been inspiring so many ever
since her breakout 2013 appearance on
abby's ultimate dance competition
followed by dance moms in 2014. i cannot
believe that i'm here right now i
honestly want abby to teach me abby is a
huge personality dance moms was so
amazing such a good experience i mean
all the cast all the crew on that show
it's amazing i was on for two and a half
years of my life and i would never go
back and change something like it was
perfect i couldn't imagine it to be any
better and she keeps inspiring proudly
coming out as a member of the lgbtq plus
community in 2021 i have gotten
the most endless amount of love and
support and it is
i'm just
she even made history that same year by
becoming the first ever dancing with the
stars competitor with a same-sex partner
you know i just want to live life and i
just want to have fun and jojo has
always maintained a really positive
attitude i think that kids should be
allowed to be what they want to be you
can do what you put your mind to she's
also an advocate against online hate to
me it's not okay and so i like to stand
up for myself that gets bullied and also
for other people professionally jojo is
on a roll five years after sharing her
goals with us there's two paths that i
think i'm gonna go in five years i think
i'm either gonna go really far down the
acting path and i feel like i would be
like a funny comedic actor or i feel
like i would go into the pop star half
where i would be like the singer and
but like see i want to do this where i
do both while she still has so much
ahead jojo is now one of the newest
judges on so you think you can dance
this is your first time judging so you
think you can dance right
what type of judge are you gonna be
listen i think i'm the honest one i
think i just like because in real life
too i just say it how it is